[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Nason adil par VAR who is a
postdoctoral associate and lecturer in
the program in Iranian studies at the
Council on Middle East Studies through a
rice faculty fellowship professor Adil
var pars primary research interests
around the nature of social relations
and conflict-affected and transitional
contexts he currently works with the
UNDP
in Iraq to engage minorities and
vulnerable groups and political and
legislative processes today we'll talk
with him about the changing nature of
ethnic and religious identity in
Afghanistan's Bamian Valley welcome
professor thank you very much it's good
to be here let's start with an overview
of your research tell us about it
so my research focuses in essence on
political reconstruction in post 2001
Afghanistan and the impacts for
intergroup relations so I did my
fieldwork for the research in Bamiyan
which is a valley in the central
highlands area of Afghanistan and it's
also the essential ancestral home sorry
for the Hazara community the Hazara are
an ethnic Shia minority but there are
two other major communities there one is
the target community which is an ethnic
Sunni community and also the saudade
community and they are descendants of
the Prophet Muhammad and that gives them
a particular religious charisma which
they used to enter into like interrelate
with the government between the Hazara
community and the government and also
more generally in terms of religious
leadership in that community so they are
seen to have more prestige because of
that connection traditionally and
typically that's the case okay so why
Afghanistan what led you to be
interested in this region of the world
well I my heritage is one of the reasons
that kind of brings me to that mind my
father's Iranian my mother thing
I grew up in the UK but essentially one
of my interest was to work overseas in
that part of the world generally
speaking which took me to Afghanistan
and I went there initially to work with
the UN in about 2006 and I spent two or
three years working with the UN and
small local organizations on various
development interventions but one of the
things that I found is that as security
deteriorated my engagement in the
engagement of the internationally as a
whole was very limited with our Afghan
counterparts so became frustrating
policies based on assumptions about
what's happening and I wanted to kind of
overcome that and doing research on the
ground for an extended period of one way
of doing that and then really as I
started to look at that kind of research
process the sociological and
anthropological literature on
Afghanistan it became clear that
ethnicity was one entry point and given
my own background my mixed heritage it
was something that initially I I
connected with and I really wanted to
explore so it's both a professional and
personal journey when you're doing the
research I would imagine there's not a
lot of written work to draw from is that
correct
and then I'd like to have you talk a
little bit about how your academic work
has contributed to the field
sure yeah you're absolutely right
there's the literature particular and
identity in Afghanistan is very
fractured it's very outdated because
limited research has been done since
1970s not 79 when the conflict started
in the country with the Soviet
occupation so there are some pieces of
work which do talk about the Hazara
community for example but there's very
little little there really to build upon
so what I wanted to do was to contribute
academically and empirically to that
that gap as it were and I think there
was three things that I really wanted to
talk to you the first was the literature
on national integration and power
sharing and what I really wanted to do
is take the the ships that took place in
Afghanistan after the Constitution was
ratified in 2004 and look at those
implications as it comes down to local
levels to individuals to those
communities that I mentioned earlier was
one area
the second is really to talk
specifically to the Afghanistan specific
academic literature that conceptually
it's very fragmented it's quite dated so
trying to draw together that literature
the concepts
present a new idea or state-of-the-art
kind of thinking on ethnicity an
identity and then empirically the third
area is to document what's going on and
as I said earlier there are there are
some pieces of literature which look at
the Hazara community but I wanted to
look at contemporary changes areas for
violence areas for for tension how
that's happening on what basis is
happening to really kind of open that
discussion up and what years are you
looking at again well the field work was
done 2010 to 12 as part of my PhD but
I'm going back even to the end of the
19th century starting there looking at
the formation of ethnicity and identity
but more post 2004 but particularly at
that period that I did my fieldwork okay
so you had mentioned the I know there's
chronic insecurity in Afghanistan so
when you're doing your field work during
that two-year time period tell us about
that were you ever concerned and I know
you also were working with a variety of
other students to to assist you in doing
your work so tell us about that field or
process well it's obviously not an easy
place to do work that was one of the
reasons that I selected Bamiyan was not
only because of the ethnic diversity but
because it's one of these safest
provinces in Afghanistan you know we're
just getting access to do that it was a
five-month ethical clearance process
with the University which was
unprecedented for my colleagues at the
time and there's two main concerns that
one was primarily about the safety of my
research participants those I was
interviewing and also my safety so we
took some of the typical academic steps
in terms of informed consent making sure
that people knew the danger they were
placing themselves in which clearly they
did and also anonymizing information
making sure it was securely stored but
in terms of actually doing the research
the the main way that we thought the
main way that my security was ensured
was I was hosted by an international
organization that has a
office there I stayed in their
guesthouse which thankfully is in the
center of one of the communities that I
was working with but did post some
challenges in terms of isolating me from
that community and I was subject to
security information coming from the
organization so on three occasions I can
think of I was unable to go to the
community or the village that I wanted
to go to because of some kind of
smoldering conflict or some tensions
that had been perceived or kind of
through kind of intelligence or
gathering information so we had to kind
of reorganize the schedule but generally
speaking it it unfold without any major
problems which is always good right
that's great so when you're in doing
your fieldwork did you were there any
surprises that you just did not
anticipate yeah I think one of the big
ones you mentioned about the students I
was working with and they were from a
local university University of Pavia
one of the first interviews I remember
doing was going to interview a member of
the saudade community and he was quite a
important figure and I went with my two
Hazara colleagues one that was
translating for me of supporting and
translation and one that was note-taking
and it was a really awkward and
comfortable kind of encounter which I I
kind of cut short and afterwards I was
kind of talking to you you know my
colleagues about what exactly went wrong
and it became obvious very quickly that
because we're talking about Hazara
saudade relationships it's political
it's sensitive it was uncomfortable
because of the team I was working with
so what I ended up having to do was to
work with three teams two men and two
women from each of those ethnic
communities so I had a team of twelve in
the end simultaneously doing research so
once we got around that obstacle it was
then a case of actually managing the
volume of work that was going on and
making sure it was transcribed correctly
which was intensive but produce a lot of
really good data at the end okay and
tell me about tell me about some
specific examples of tensions that are
that you attract while you're there well
I looked at two main case studies
between the as IRA Tariq dimension and
the Hazara so dot dimension and in the
the the latter case the as we mentioned
nearly the Saadat community have this
let's say
religious superiority or at least
perceived that way because of
historically the role they've played in
the Hazara community and the they've
always taken wives from the Hazara
community often a second wives but never
given their daughters to be married to
them as our community so it really
exemplifies that power relationship but
what's happening now is that has our
community with an increasing status
that's come from the way the state has
reorganized and allocate resources in
Bamiyan they started to say well why
can't we Mary there's nothing
religiously that stops us it's just a
tradition so there's increase in cases
of elopement taking place now in Bamiyan
in which has are a man run away with
society women but the soldered community
retaliates very violently to try and
maintain that relationship and although
there are political reasons this is one
of the interfaces at which the two
communities are really kind of coming
apart and differ a check differentiating
themselves and I've tried to document
that that process on the flip side
looking at the target community I've
looked very much at morning rituals and
one in particular which is Ashura which
really looks at the oppression that the
Shia community in this case that has our
community has faced historically at the
hands of Sunni communities of the Sunni
State and the way it's articulated to
you so we find very much that somewhat
through Iranian influence in terms of
the way these rituals are played out
you're seeing an increasing tension
being driven between these two sectarian
groups and this has happened after 2004
once the Constitution recognized the
ability for the Shia community to
practice their rituals so again I've
tried to demonstrate and look at that
cleavage as it kind of opens up between
those communities okay and what do you
conclude ultimately well I think there's
three main things I conclude the first
is really looking at the very earth Nick
nature in which the state is now
operating since 2001 and again that goes
back to the Constitution the way the
government has been structured the way
resources are allocated and that really
shows that this has become a modus
operandi of the way the government
functions the way that people make
claims or communities make claims
against the state for greater security
more resources or services
and the way that the president
particular appeals to those communities
to try win votes and then saying that
because there's this kind of ethnic
nature of politics ethnic identities
become increasingly salient or prominent
in everyday life for better or for worse
and personally I don't think you know
increasing social differentiation is a
good thing so I don't think that long
run that's going to have a great impact
on Afghan Society secondly I think it's
also important to recognize that this
process of political reconstruction or
development more generally is actually
or potentially a violent process as I
mentioned earlier these changing
relationships between groups when you're
you know challenging old inequalities
can result in violence and I think we
need to understand that better I think
we need to work to mitigate that better
both in terms of the state and the
international community and the last
area which is more a general set of
findings that my research outlines is
really just understanding the way that
ethnicity or ethnic identity functions
in the case of Bamiyan and to show how
that functions and to understand better
the need for political analysis and for
the workings and everyday settings which
is something that really hasn't been
done adequately in the context of
Afghanistan and on that note will you be
pursuing a further research there on
those issues yeah Zak actually were
hosting a conference again in April
which will start to open up those issues
about identity not just ethnic identity
but other forms of identity which could
range from the impact of returnees
coming back and having effect on older
and younger generations and the way that
that is deployed or functions in Afghan
society there's a whole host of areas
who hope to hope to open up and to
publish on in the coming year or so okay
well thank you so much for being here
today and think about your work thanks
for more information about professor
adler Parv r and his work please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies
yeah
you